at least the guys that are attracted to
me are like oh yes like superwoman like
this woman who's like successful hot and
then they're actually in the
relationship and they're experiencing
what it's like to be around somebody who
has like a lot going on and a lot of
whatever and they start to get resentful
and you're like but I thought that's why
you liked me like I thought that's what
you liked about me it was how
opinionated I was they don't care here's
what men actually value in women
according to Pure research physical
attractiveness is right up there but
right next to it is empathy in kindness
intelligence honesty morality
professional or financial success are
now down to 8% independent self-
Reliance 6% we don't men don't care
you're trying to make yourself
attractive to a man in the way that a
man makes himself attractive to you yes
to most women a man who can provide a
man who can protect a man who makes a
good living that matters to you we
couldn't care less